[Musique]
Paris 16 juin 2039
les stations de métro sont prises
d'assaut les Parisiens se réfugient sous
terre
sur ordre de la préfecture toutes les
salles de spectacle tous les musées
parisiens sont réquisitionnés pour
accueillir les plus fragiles
il est 11h30 et pour la première fois
Paris vient de franchir la barre des 50
degrés
[Musique]
sur les routes dans les gares c'est la
panique générale les familles tentent de
fuir la capitale
le scénario est fictif mais la mérite
Paris s'y prépare déjà un exercice de
crise sera même organisé l'an prochain
les vagues de chaleur sont plus
fréquentes plus intenses plus longues
aussi à tarberpo le thermomètre à
dépasser les 30 degrés plus de 29 à ce
mois d'octobre et le plus chaud jamais
enregistré en France
cette température là le 25 décembre un
jour là ce sera vraiment inquiétant
t'inquiète pour moi je me demande aussi
pour mes enfants en effet comment ils
vont ils vont ils vont s'adapter et
[Musique]
en fait le climat va plus vite que notre
réaction aujourd'hui
[Musique]
des villes bien trop minérales qui si
l'on ne fait rien pourrait devenir
invivable
[Musique]
le risque c'est qu'une rue comme ça on y
aille plus que ce soit juste même risqué
pour sa propre santé en fait
alors comment préparer nos villes à
faire face aux changements climatiques
certains imaginent des solutions pour
lutter contre les îlots de chaleur
c'est la technologie de chlorophymes ça
veut dire que c'est de la peinture qui
va rafraîchir les bâtiments
d'autres ont pris de l'avance en misant
sur l'énergie solaire
nous on est peut-être parti un peu plus
tôt que bon nombre de collectivités et
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est qu'on
est eu raison de partir un peu plus tôt
maintenant que la ville de 2050 doit
s'inventer
face au changement climatique une course
contre la montre est engagée
[Musique]
nous partons dans l'un des
arrondissements de Paris où le bitume
règne en maître
l'un des quartiers les plus chauds ou
cet été le sol est monté jusqu'à 65
degrés
avenue de l'Opéra en plein centre de la
capitale
nous avons rendez-vous avec Franck
lierzin
cette ingénieur en immobilier s'inquiète
aujourd'hui de la capacité de Paris à
faire face aux changements climatique on
le voit il y a pas un arbre le sol est
entièrement bitumé vous avez ces
immeubles haussmanniens qui sont en
pierre avec des toits qui sont en
ardoise une rue qui est orientée plein
sud donc ça veut dire que l'été quand le
soleil est au zénith il tombe
directement ici sur la rue et donc ça
chauffe cette ce bitume qui est noir et
donc qui absorbe la chaleur et quand la
nuit arrive le sol les murs restitue
cette chaleur et donc forment ce qu'on
appelle des îlots de chaleur urbaine un
îlot de chaleur et une avenue bloquée
d'un côté par l'opéra de l'autre par le
Louvre qui empêche l'air de circuler
résultat impossible de rafraîchir la rue
les thés les piétons suffoquent et dans
les immeubles les habitants étouffent
et donc c'est façades elles sont
complètement exposées au soleil donc
elles vont chauffer la pierre va
emmagasiné la chaleur et quand ça se
passe comme ça pendant 1 2 10 jours de
suite donc pendant une période de
canicule on a une pierre qui atteint les
30-35 degrés à l'intérieur des logements
et qui la nuit va du coup être comme un
radiateur et donc on va chauffer les
logements
et haussmannien et l'exemple type d'un
pari devenu inadapté pourtant à sa
construction au 19e siècle il était à la
pointe de l'innovation a été construit à
la fin du petit âge glaciaire donc on
l'oublie souvent mais le petit âge
Gatien se termine en 1850 c'est l'époque
où commence les travaux de Haussmann
donc à l'époque l'enjeu principal c'est
pas la chaleur c'est le froid et donc
c'est pour ça qu'à l'époque ils ont
introduit des innovations notamment
d'avoir des des chauffages dans tous les
bâtiments qui sont raccordés donc c'est
pour ça qu'on voit sur les toits
d'ailleurs toutes les toutes les
cheminées
et donc la ville n'a pas été conçue pour
cette chaleur là tout simplement parce
que ça n'existait pas à l'époque
mais vous allez voir que récemment
encore certains aménagements urbains ont
fait filles du changement climatique
direction la station de métro Bercy
en 2018 la gare est transformée une
partie du sous-sol est agrandi
avant ici en fait tout cet espace où on
est là c'était la terre et en fait le la
circulation pour la ligne 6 et la ligne
14 se faisait par un petit couloir dont
le voilà qui était pas suffisant par
rapport au nombre de personnes qui
passaient et donc la décision a été a
été prise de créer en fait tout cet
espace qui n'existait pas donc les pacs
ici les billettrés sur le côté un accès
par là et puis cette grande esplanade
beaucoup enfin cette grande espace
beaucoup plus important
de les travaux ont été faits
principalement pour des questions de
confort des voyageurs pour plus de
fluidité entre les lignes et ce sujet
climatique a été oublié
on sait qu'en surface la place a été
réaménagée et entièrement bitumé avant
il y avait des arbres donc il me reste
quelques survivants ici qui sont des
magnifiques lilas de Perse et avant il y
en avait une douzaine qui était sur
cette place là et donc c'était une place
qui était ombragée et beaucoup plus
agréable l'été
ça paraît évident mais créer de l'ombre
en ville c'est gagner en fraîcheur même
en ce mois d'octobre la différence est
flagrante
ne se déplace jamais sans sa caméra
thermique
voilà donc là ça permet de mesurer la
température sur la place on est à peu
près à 26 degrés au niveau du bitume et
quand on regarde à Londres on descend à
14 degrés donc on perd plus de 10 degrés
entre la partie exposée au soleil et la
partie à Londres
on a supprimé les arbres on a mis du
bitume on l'a transformé en fournaise et
on a été obligé de remettre ses
ombrières pour apporter un peu d'ombre
qu'on a fait disparaître en coupant ces
lilas
une hérésie
car végétalisait la ville est
indispensable si l'on veut lutter contre
l'effet de four urbain en plein été
l'arbre comme climatiseur naturel
[Musique]
les filles est-ce que vous voulez
arroser un petit coup ouais allez
un arrosoir vous allez remplir depuis
deux ans Marc Pacôme plus souvent son
costume de jardinier qui c'est qui vient
arroser les plantes que celui
d'animateur lecture
allez vous remplissez arrosez les
plantes avec les enfants c'est même
devenu un rituel
si on veut qu'elles aillent tout en haut
là il faut leur donner à boire très bien
le fait de construire des projets comme
ça avec les enfants déjà ça les
sensibilise
des plantes grimpantes des arbres des
copeaux sols et des structures en bois
la cour de cette école élémentaire a
bien changé
excite le bitume elle est devenue ce
qu'on appelle une cour oasis
avant avant ça c'était rien du tout
respirer parce que avant c'était il y
avait pas beaucoup de plantes là c'est
beaucoup mieux
l'idée de ce projet c'était surtout de
gagner en fraîcheur cet été plusieurs
écoles ont dû fermer la chaleur
empêchait les enfants de sortir dans les
cours
[Musique]
2026 la mairie de Paris envisage ainsi
de planter 160
000 nouveaux arbres
lutter contre la surchauffe des villes
c'est aussi adapter la à existante
cette immeuble par exemple
16 étages de simples vitrages exposées
plein sud sans aucune protection
pourtant à l'époque cet immeuble
d'après-guerre était à la fois une
prouesse architecturale et un progrès
technique considérable
contrairement au bâtiment haussmannien
dont les façades sont porteuses donc
c'est pour ça que c'est de la pierre
avec une certaine inertie ici la
structure porteuse a été mise à
l'intérieur et donc ça a pu permettre de
mettre des façades esthétiques immenses
mais des passeurs thermiques
le bâtiment
Franck lesingt a été confronté à
l'époque où il gérait cette immeuble
ça nécessite effectivement
d'imaginer que cet immeuble là on est
capable de retirer intégralement la
façade avec des gens qui habitent dedans
et de remettre quelque chose de
complètement différent
c'est faisable mais c'est compliqué
parce qu'il faut à la fois concilier un
défi technologique majeur on sait pas
aujourd'hui totalement appréhender le
sujet et en même temps il faut préserver
la qualité architecturale ça fait partie
des grands noms d'architecture française
c'est une trame écossaise de Dubuisson
et donc il y a une esthétique à
conserver un challenge technique trop
coûteux estimé à 20 millions d'euros
à 400 km de là à Rennes
agripper à l'échelle lunettes de soleil
sur les yeux Julien Martin Cochet nous
emmène voir ses équipes à 12 mètres de
haut on se croirait sur une piste
enneigée ici la réverbération est
maximale comme les sols les toitures
sont au première loge du rayonnement
solaire
alors on est sur un magasin de bricolage
14000 mètres carrés et aujourd'hui les
équipes ont appliqué trois couches de
coolrouf c'est du de la peinture
thermorététique passive ça veut dire que
les rayons du soleil viennent tapent ce
qu'on appelle une enveloppe là ici c'est
un support bitumineux et en fait avec
cette peinture 90% des rayons sont
renvoyés vers l'extérieur
ça veut dire que c'est de la peinture
qui va rafraîchir les bâtiments et voilà
donc là ils sont en train d'appliquer la
troisième couche et c'est la couche
technique
une peinture qui bloque la chaleur
l'idée n'est pas nouvelle
l'aérospatiale l'utilise déjà mais si ça
fonctionne sur les fusées pourquoi pas
sur les toits
le directeur du magasin découvre pour la
première fois sa toiture repeinte et
donc rafraîchie
ça ça bougera pas de 35 degrés 35 degrés
en plaignait en plein été la différence
là vous étiez en train de toucher
tout de suite on sent la chaleur
donc j'imagine que en dessous aussi
forcément
thermique le flux thermique donc voilà
ça suit et c'est la dispersion de la
chaleur effectivement on sent vraiment
la différence là alors qu'il est quelle
heure il est 11h30 donc on n'est pas
encore au pic je pense
pour que ce soit encore plus parlant les
équipes mesureront l'efficacité de la
peinture blanche grâce à des capteurs
posés sur le toit
une zone témoin en Béthune noire et
conservée
56 degrés sur la partie pour l'instant
pas encore avec un soleil au zénith et
on va regarder le blanc
on va être à 27 26 26 27
gré sur le Tour
à l'intérieur du magasin la température
pourrait baisser de 6 à 7 degrés c'est
autant de climatisation éviter
là faut s'imaginer on est 12 mètres sous
toiture et donc l'été quand il fait
chaud il fait chaud également dans le
magasin même avec
la meilleure volonté du monde même étant
les climatisations
enfin des températures basses finalement
il fait encore chaud et surtout là avec
ce que j'ai vu au là-haut je l'espère en
tout cas on aura des températures plus
agréables et surtout on consomme
évidemment moins d'énergie
entreprise
c'est il y a 7 ans et elle a déjà équipé
500 mille mètres carrés de toiture comme
celle-ci
avec les pics caniculaires qu'on a eu
cet été les gens réfléchissent
aujourd'hui différemment donc ils sont
plus ouverts à des technologies qui sont
pas qui sont innovantes mais qui sont
pas si récentes que ça ça fait des
milliers d'années que c'est posé en
Grèce aux États-Unis en Inde et voilà
les toits blancs ou les murs blancs ça
fait longtemps que ça existe
alors peut-on refroidir nos villes d'un
simple coup de pinceau
[Musique]
en tout cas il est en Europe un milliard
de mètres carrés de toiture disponible
aux premières loges du réchauffement
climatique en France Marseille comme
toutes les villes du Sud et si les défis
à relever sont considérables
l'avenir de la métropole se joue au nord
en bord de mer sur d'anciennes friches
industrielles le quartier
Euroméditerranée
christiane a quitté son ancien logement
étouffant pour s'installer ici il y a 3
ans
les immeubles là-bas il avait 60 ans
tandis qu'ici c'est tout neuf il faisait
froid l'hiver et très chaud à l'été
puisqu'il n'y avait pas de double
vitrage il y avait pas de voler roulant
donc voilà c'était des rideaux
occultants que je m'étais
ici ça n'a l'air de rien mais
l'appartement est traversant donc l'air
peut circuler
j'ouvre voilà donc je cale parce
qu'après il y a des petits courants
d'air
et donc après voilà j'ouvre et ça nous
fait de les courants d'air donc
l'appartement il est bien frais
[Musique]
et coucou bonjour bienvenue comment ça
va
oh tu nous a amené des petites
plantations sur le toit une terrasse
commune végétalisée tout est adapté au
climat
[Musique]
méditerranéennes d'accord donc c'est
bien l'eau de mer toute proche et
recyclée elle permet de chauffer les
logements par thalasso thermie un
quartier et correspondable j'ai un
appartement au nord
j'ai pas besoin de clim j'ai pas besoin
de j'ai pas de soleil direct j'ai du
soleil six mois dans l'année le matin à
l'est et le soir à l'ouest et on est
très bien chauffé
par rapport à c'est clair avant j'avais
72 euros de
d'électricité par mois il m'a là j'ai 34
6 mois et 6 mois 22
les maîtres penseurs de ce nouveau
quartier bioclimatique sont François
Leclerc architectes urbaniste à droite
et Rémi Costantino directeur du
développement de reméditerranée dans
cette îlot ils ont imaginé une
architecture à l'écoute des éléments qui
jouent avec le soleil et le vent on a
décidé de fabriquer une suite
d'immeubles des uns que des autres mais
séparés par des largeurs de rue qui
permet de laisser passer l'air
c'est-à-dire on se protège du vent mais
en même temps on en profite quand il
fait chaud il y a des bruits de marines
qui traversent l'eau qui permet de
rafraîchir
au centre un jardin pour que la ville
soit vivable il faut l'aérer
c'est juste trouver cette jauge entre
ces lieux livres on va voir des espaces
publics des espaces portés mais en même
temps garder cette aspect presque
historique de fabrique de l'ombre
créer de l'ombre pour éviter la
surchauffe des villes
[Musique]
derrière ces immeubles neufs une énorme
friche industrielle
en réalité c'est un laboratoire à ciel
ouvert
ici Euroméditerranée test les bâtiments
et les matériaux de demain
et pour Rémi Costantino ça se passe sous
nos pieds sur ses revêtements innovants
des sols nouvelle génération d'abord ils
sont fermés ils sont testés sur leur
capacité à recevoir la goutte d'eau la
goutte de pluie et à la faire tout de
suite traversée donc les matériaux sont
pour eux
vous avez des trous des parfois des trop
visibles ou alors des micro trous qui
absorbent l'eau
des seuls absorbants car ici plus que
les canicules à venir ce sont les pluies
intenses et les inondations qui
inquiètent et notamment les épisodes 10
cévenols c'est-à-dire c'est très forte
pluie qu'on connaît à l'automne qui d'un
coup amène énormément d'eau et toute
l'eau qui s'est infiltrée ici c'est
autant d'eau qui n'ira pas débordé en
aval infiltrer l'eau c'est ne pas avoir
ensuite à la transporter dans les
réseaux donc c'est une vraie économie
d'argent facilité de gestion et
réduction du risque
un peu caché un peu oublié au fond de ce
parc la rivière des Aygalades
elle a longtemps disparu enterré sous
une partie de la ville François Leclerc
veut lui redonner vie
et l'idée c'est de découvrir tout ça
pour avoir une sorte de de rivière
visible une sorte de parcours une sorte
de promenade de GR qui aille de la mer à
la montagne ou de la montagne à la mer
la rivière coule en réalité
sous ses rails
[Musique]
et ici l'architecte voit grand
transformer ses voies de chemin de fer
en un immense poumon vert en plein
quartier nord de Marseille
au milieu les égalades le projet prévoit
qu'en cas de pluie le parc puisse
absorber le trop-plein de la rivière
l'idée c'est que il pourra recevoir
l'eau de manière substantielle pour
éviter que l'eau se propage et aille
dans les dans les habitations et
quartier d'éducation qui sont autour
c'est la notion du inondation maîtrisée
finalement et à parc résilient par
rapport à ces deux sont de risque et
bien sûr il y a cette notion de
thermique de chaleur c'est à dire ce
sera un vrai îlot de fraîcheur par
rapport à des quartiers assez minéraux
qui sont tout autour
le futur parc des Aygalades devrait voir
le jour d'ici 4 ans
nous sommes en Normandie dans un jardin
potager entre tenu par les habitants au
pied des immeubles
rien de bien original la première vue
sauf que dans cette petite ville
normande c'est la municipalité qui a
financé le projet l'idée crée du lien
entre les habitants sur fond d'écologie
[Musique]
ça reste vert il y a des arbres il y a
des potagers il y a des fleurs partout
il y a de l'écologie il y a plein de
choses comme ça et je pense que c'est
une petite particularité quand même chez
nous qu'on a pas ailleurs qui est dû à
quoi
le maire de Malaunay c'est lui Guillaume
coutais il a décidé de faire de sa
commune de 6000 habitants un modèle de
ville durable
et pour lui ça passe avant tout par les
économies d'énergie
s'il nous a donné rendez-vous à l'église
ce n'est pas par hasard sur son toit il
est installé ses premiers panneaux
solaires il y a 10 ans
on veut que sur l'espace public que ça
puisse avoir un écho interpellé suscité
des questions voire du débat et
symboliquement on a voulu commencer par
l'Église pour justement sensibiliser les
habitants du territoire mais aussi
celles et ceux qui passent par malhonnet
sur un enjeu qui est celui de la
production d'énergie renouvelable
30% de la consommation de malhonnêtes et
produite grâce au photovoltaïques en
disant la ville a diminué de moitié ses
émissions de CO2
[Musique]
ce qui fait qu'en termes de dépenses
d'argent public c'est plutôt bien pour
le porte-monnaie de la ville et c'est
bien aussi en termes d'émission de
carbone on a là sur une production qui
est à 0 carbone
[Musique]
des panneaux solaires Guillaume coutais
en a installé partout sur ses bâtiments
municipaux
[Musique]
l'ancienne chaufferie de la piscine est
couverte en solaire
le boulot de Drôme
on l'a également couvert en solaire
[Musique]
les deux groupes scolaires de la ville
ont été transformés aussi couverts avec
des tuiles solaires
au total
en mètres carrés de panneaux solaires
recouvre les toits de malhonnête
on fait la démonstration sur le temps
long que nos investissements autour de
l'efficacité énergétique autour des
énergies renouvelables nous permettent
de contenir l'augmentation des prix et
en plus de faire des économies
financières
[Musique]
Guillaume Coutet veut aller plus loin
il lorgne sur chaque espace disponible
pour implanter du solaire
cette société industrielle par exemple
des toits des parkings des surfaces
idéales pour son nouveau projet
[Musique]
d'intégrer sa communauté énergétique
citoyenne
[Musique]
faisons une communauté énergétique
citoyenne sur tout le territoire ce qui
permettrait de produire l'électricité
d'autoconsommer comme nous on fait sur
pour le patrimoine bureau et usine et
que le surplus soit géré par cette
communauté et moi du coup ville je
pourrais acheter cette électricité à la
communauté énergétique Citroën et donc
bien moins cher que l'électricité qu'on
peut acheter auprès des fournisseurs
traditionnels effectivement ce serait de
pouvoir déployer sur le site et non pas
que sur le bâti un ensemble de
dispositifs solaires où l'énergie
collectée mais non consommée par le site
puisse être redistribués
auprès de la commune et des citoyens
c'est quelque chose est à l'étude ce
sont des investissements aussi qui sont
qui sont conséquents merci pour ta
visite merci à toi
mais ce modèle de ville résiliente de
6000 habitants
établables partout
[Musique]
pour rendre les métropoles vivables ils
vont en tout cas falloir repenser leur
physionomie
Franck lerzin en est convaincu
à Paris pour lutter contre la canicule
la ville devra peut-être un jour
renoncée à ces fameux toits en zinc
malisolé pour les végétaliser ou les
peindre en blanc quand vous vivez dans
une capitale où vous avez un tiers de
l'année il fait extrêmement chaud est-ce
que vous trouvez agréable d'avoir des
toits métalliques partout c'est pas sûr
et peut-être que demain ce qui sera beau
ce sera pas c'est toi métallique mais ce
sera le vert ou le blanc et donc je
pense que l'esthétique de Paris peut
changer et le regard comporte sur Paris
peut être adapté mais c'est difficile de
rester dans un statut court qui va
devenir de moins en moins acceptable
imaginez les centres urbains de demain
plus respirable tout en préservant leur
patrimoine architectural
le défi est d'autant plus grand que la
ville de 2050 existe déjà 80% dans son
bâti et dans sa forme
[Musique]